what's up wisecrack
jared again director ari aster stunned
and delighted horror fans with his 2018
familial horror film hereditary
so expectations for his follow-up were
understandably high and according to
contemporary horror king jordan peele
astor more than met those expectations
creating quote
the most idyllic horror film of all time
now peel enjoys his horror film served
with a healthy side of social commentary
and deep meaning as we've covered in our
videos on get out and
us so his response got us thinking is
there something meaningful going on in
this gnarly vision of the swedish
countryside
or is it all bear carcasses and no
substance let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on midsomar
or midsummer i'm just going to call it
midsummer deep
or dumb and as always spoilers ahead
alright let's dive into a recap
midsummer introduces us to 20-something
dany and her douchey boyfriend christian
who's about to dump her but when dany's
sister
kills herself and her parents christian
can't
exactly peace out motivated by guilt he
unenthusiastically invites her to tag
along with him and his anthropology grad
school bros
on a trip to sweden for a special once
every 96 years mid-summer festival
they arrive at an idyllic swedish
commune and almost
immediately gets weird two old people
jump off a cliff in a harakiri esque
ritual
this chick puts a pube in christian's
pie and people dance and moan while
tripping balls
these british people are reasonably like
wear out and promptly disappear
has anyone seen connie things get
progressively creepier and the grad
school bros are subsequently killed
one by one in creatively horrifying
fashion
but things are going comparatively
better for dany who wins an
all-girls stone dance competition gets
crowned may queen and is celebrated by
the whole community
then christian gets roped into a weird
sex ritual that dany sees through a
keyhole
but she doesn't have long to mope
because there's about to be a cool human
sacrifice
and she gets to select the ninth person
to be set on fire
we patiently wait your verdict she
picks you guessed it christian danny
smiles as he and his fellow sacrificial
lamb humans burn
the end to figure out if this film is
deep or not we first have to decipher
astor's bloody depiction of a midsummer
festival
it's important to note that this film is
not overly concerned with total
anthropological fidelity
midsummer though an iconic swedish
holiday is not a bloodbath where
grandpas jump
off cliffs or hapless foreigners are put
in funny hats and burn to a crisp
according to poe tid holm author of the
book celebrating the swedish way
midsummer is all about celebrating
summer eating herring
drinking aqua beet and staying up late
it is a light and happy tradition
he notes that it is held to welcome
summertime and the season of fertility
and involves dancing around maples
decorating everything with ferns and
plants and visiting holy springs
as for that death ritual title also
clarifies that to the best of his
knowledge there have never been any
sacrifices on midsummer
not even in ancient times and what about
the weird sex stuff
that was completely the twisted
brainchild of astor
however babymaking is a big part of
midsummer which is why a lot of swedes
are born a square nine months after the
sexy solstice
cool and about those psychedelics
apparently celebrating swedes are far
more likely to get boozy than they are
to trip balls
duly noted but don't go thinking aster
made up everything during a particularly
industrious acid trip
dude did his homework spending months
researching and eventually drawing from
swedish traditions and folklore
as well as norse mythology indeed harga
is a real rural village
and much of the film's imagery is
consistent with real swedish midsummer
celebrations
complete with a maypole similarly the
somewhat creepy paintings on the barn
walls are also true to real agrarian
swedish societies
people really do eat herring and wear
flower wreaths aster also plucked other
religious traditions like the blessing
of the crops
from a famous 19th century
anthropological study by james george
fraser
these lighter details all faithful to
swedish culture
are complicated by the film's darker
turns but we'll get to that later
astor even went so far as to learn the
scandinavian runic alphabet
which was used to write germanic
languages in northwestern europe before
the adaptation of the latin alphabet
he told the ringer that every item of
hargra clothing is decorated in
specifically chosen runic symbols
and in different hieroglyphic language
they invented specifically for the film
a notable example comes when christian
dons a white robe before entering the
world's weirdest fertility ceremony
the robe is decorated with the upwards
arrow tiwas symbol
associated with the nordic god tier who
represents bravery masculine
energy and virility fittingly tears
sacrifices his hand to save the world
which is appropriate for a dude who's
about to be
well sacrificed dany in contrast has two
runes on her dress that showcase her
character's duality
an r-shaped rivo which symbolizes
journey and an hourglass-shaped thawgaus
rune which could mean new beginning
or loss of hope both symbols are up for
interpretation but each feel relevant to
danny's journey
as far as the death stuff goes aster was
likely inspired
by long debated viking mythology and
folklore
certain written and visual accounts from
the prehistoric viking period depict
sacrifices of horses
dogs birds and yes humans which
apparently occurred every 9 years
these accounts have been disputed by
scholars but they pretty much agree that
if human beings were sacrificed
it probably happened before 10 50 a.d so
regardless some creative liberties are
being taken other striking moments are
also infused with elements of norse
mythology
for instance christian is put inside a
bear carcass before being burned alive
bears are significant in norse mythology
viking men donned bare skins before
battle
and some even believe that the skins
protected them from fire
perhaps even more grotesque is the fate
of simon the british guy who kristen
finds splayed open his lungs
somehow still breathing this gruesome
sight is a reenactment of the blood
eagle
a viking torture ritual that involves
inside outing a dude
the blood eagle was first documented in
865 but scholars are unsure whether it's
possible
and none have exactly volunteered to be
the guinea pig then there are the harga
love rituals
some of which bear resemblance to
reality for instance we see the harga
young women picking different types of
flowers
in real life they would pick 7 different
kinds of flowers and put them under
their pillow to conjure dreams of their
future mate
instead christian seducer maya places a
carved love rune under his bed
in a more shocking moment christian
discovers a pubic hair in his pie
a love spell astor insists comes from
actual swedish folklore
at a different point christian's drink
is slightly redder than the others
suggesting that there's menstrual blood
in there which aster also says comes
from lore
we've had trouble confirming either
practice and attempting to
made the people at the library think
that we're weirdos so don't say we don't
make sacrifices for you guys
anyway the point is that astor had fun
combining truth and fiction
old and new mythology and history to
build his creepy haven of cell
phone-free agrarian life for ritualized
human sacrifice
is as normal as sourdough bread that's
certainly not a criticism
if every horror film was confined to
reality the genre would be pretty boring
but in using this potpourri of
references
is aster trying to make a deeper point
let's look at the two very different
ways the film's outsider characters
react to these rituals
we'll start with dany who despite the
demented arsenal that's going down
ends the film with a smile what are we
supposed to make of this
has dany become evil or is there
something more to it
we think so and her character arc proves
it danny begins the film pretty firmly
ensconced in a cold
alienating secular society filled with
icy
lonely city streets the colors are muted
and we get the sense that this is not a
happy world
after losing her entire family nobody
really comforts dany
and her boyfriend only stays with her to
seem like a good guy
her world feels pretty absent of
community and emotional support
she's shown alone in her house with
phone calls providing much of her
communication with the outside world
her detachment is apparent in her first
phone call with christian
the camera is set squarely on her face
without a single cut to him
implying that she's talking to somebody
who isn't fully present
i'm very lucky to have you several other
conversations are shown in mirrors which
could imply that people aren't really
connecting
and are only seeing each other's
superficial public face
her boyfriend is constantly trying to
get away from her
i was just gonna go to that party for 45
minutes forgets her birthday
and pressures her to take hallucinogens
despite her recurring panic attacks
early on their swedish friend pella
tells her that despite being orphaned as
a child
i have always felt held by a family
a real family which everyone deserves
you deserve it's clear what she's
lacking love
empathy and community and that's exactly
what she finds when she encounters the
harga people
now although she spends the first half
of the film extremely wary and
frightened of them
she's eventually seduced by the warmth
of their community
plus drugs the harga even seem to move
in tandem as if they're all dancing to
the same piece of choreography
they behave like different parts of the
same organism
the idea of shared catharsis both in
pain and pleasure is present throughout
the film
when this old man survives his leap off
a cliff the rest of the tribe moan in
unison
as of experiencing a collective pain
this is repeated in the final ritual
sacrifice and similarly during
christian's hot date we see the women
moan in unison with maya as if sharing
her pleasure
every feeling experienced is shared by
the community
as astor puts it their language is
empathy
at first dany's intimidated by their
sense of unity
feeling too scared to join the ritual
dancing you guys should join
oh no i'm too scared however she does
appear to be struck by the connectedness
of the people
staring closely during ceremonies after
the horrific sacrificing
dany is visibly stunned and devastated
but she listens attentively as the elder
woman explains we view life
as a circle a recycle as someone who has
recently lost
her whole family the idea of life being
a circle of rebirth
has to be attractive we see dany become
increasingly more immersed in the harga
culture
as she starts to find the cult a
community she craved
most basically this is shown in her
costume which transforms from her dark
real world clothing to an apron and
eventually a full dress and flower
wreath before the maypole dance
here she takes more hallucinogens but
this time in a ritualized motion
sharing the experience first with one
harga girl and then with the entire
circle of them
though she's slightly off rhythm she
can't avoid being led into the dance and
the dizzying experience
is the first time we see her truly smile
she's finally moving as part of the
singular harga organism but the most
important moment of the film happens
after she sees christian having sex with
rando swedish girl
she bursts into uncontrollable tears
echoing the way she cried after learning
about her family's death
except this time she's surrounded by a
group of hargo women who cry in tandem
with her
as if sharing her emotional load and
completely empathizing with her pain
interestingly dany's increased
inculcation into the cult is mirrored by
her increased
immersion into nature this begins
psychedelically when she hallucinates
her hands growing grass
and then her feet turning into grass
over the course of her may queen
rulership she becomes covered with more
and more flowers
to the point of absurdity by the end she
has almost entirely disappeared into a
gown and crown of bright blossoms
symbolizing her surrender to nature and
this agrarian society
we see this new fidelity to the harga
society when she picks
christian rather than a harga to be the
ninth sacrifice
as she watches the burning she
experiences pain but
like the harga also experiences joy
she's watching the vestiges of her
former life crumble
and can't help but smile as she is free
to start anew in a community where she
can belong
and be seen it's creepy as hell but
makes for
pretty great cinema but if you're not
interested in joining a community of
happy inbred blonde people there's
another option
enter christian and the dude bros they
approach the harga people with the
condescending distance of anthropology
students working on a thesis
sneaking into temples to take photos of
secret religious texts
or watching the rituals as if
surveilling animals at a zoo
the crazier the animals act the better a
peer-reviewed paper they'll have
meanwhile mark the unabashed fool is
more preoccupied with banging swedish
chicks and could care less about their
beliefs
as demonstrated when he pees on a sacred
tree and can't comprehend their
reactions
i just had to pee in general they
approach the harga culture with the same
detached
shock and intrigue as us an audience so
alienated from the value of ancient
rituals that were willing to buy into
the idea that they could be this
horrific
or at least buy in enough for it to
effectively scare us so what is aster
doing here
the way we see it the film is constantly
playing into and subverting
our modern secular aversion to mystical
traditions religious worship has become
increasingly alien to many of us
leading theologian david bentley heart
to write that our religion is one of
very comfortable nihilism
we tend to see ritual acts as primitive
and potentially barbaric
that this film's particular boogeyman
takes the form of very religious swedes
rather than a sadistic serial killer or
a shape-shifting clown
speaks volumes about our society's fear
and aversion to ritual
at the same time astor depicts the harga
clan as the precise answer to everything
wrong with dany's life
she's offered complete acceptance
genuine reciprocity
and total empathy thus mid-summer is a
shocking reassertion of the value of
ritual
no matter how irrational these acts may
seem they have a very rational purpose
to build community and a sense of
belonging
we'd go ahead and say that's wisecrack
certified deep
but what do you guys think is midsummer
a compelling horror show that comments
on our increasingly secular society
or is it just pagan people equals weird
[Music]